SNOE ♪
♪
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> GOOD AFTERNOON.
DISTINGUISHED
COLLEAGUES, GRADUATES, FRIENDS,
AND FAMILY. GREETINGS TO YOU
JOINING US ONLINE FROM ALL
AROUND THE WORLD.
I AM LYNN COOLEY, DEAN OF YALE
GRADUATE SCHOOL OF ARTS AND
SCIENCES, AND I AM DELIGHTED
AND
GRATEFUL TO HAVE YOU WITH US AS
WE GATHER TO CELEBRATE
ACHIEVEMENTS OF THE CLASSES OF
2020 AND 2021 OF YALE
GRADUATE SCHOOL.
[ APPLAUSE ]
TO BEGIN, I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE INDIGENOUS PEOPLES AND
NATIONS -- INCLUDING MOHEGAN,
MASHANTUCKET PEQUOT, EASTERN
PEQUOT, SCHAGHTICOKE, GOLDEN
HILL PAUGUSSETT, NIANTIC, THE
QUINNIPIAC AND OTHER ALGONQUIAN
SPEAKING PEOPLES - WHO HAVE
STEWARDED THROUGH GENERATIONS
THE LANDS AND WATERWAYS OF WHAT
IS NOW THE STATE OF
CONNECTICUT.
WE HONOR AND RESPECT THE
ENDURING RELATIONSHIP THAT
EXISTS BETWEEN THESE PEOPLES
AND
NATIONS, AND THIS LAND.
WELCOME TO OUR ALUMNI DEGREE
CEREMONY FOR THE YALE GRADUATE
SCHOOL OF ARTS AND SCIENCES.
AND I'M GOING TO GO A LITTLE
OUT OF ORDER AND SAY A VERY
HEART-FELT THANK YOU TO OUR
SUBURB ORGANIST WHO IS ONE OF
OUR MANY ACCOMPLISHED YALE
STUDENTS PLAYING ON ONE OF THE
WORLD'S GREAT PIPE ORGANS IN
WOOLSEY HALL.
THANK YOU.
[ APPLAUSE ]
THANK YOU TO OUR GRADUATES FOR
PAUSING IN YOUR POST-YALE LIVES
AND RETURNING IN
PERSON TO OUR BEAUTIFUL CAMPUS.
WE CANNOT REPLACE OR RESTORE
EVERYTHING THE PANDEMIC HAS
TAKEN FROM US, BUT TODAY WE
HAVE
A CHANCE TO REBUILD AT LEAST A
PART OF WHAT WE LOST.
AT LAST WE CAN CELEBRATE YOUR
HARD WORK AND SUCCESS,
CELEBRATE
THE BEGINNING OF YOUR
PROFESSIONAL LIVES, AND THE
MANY
WAYS IN WHICH YOU NOW SERVE THE
WORLD.
CEREMONY IS IMPORTANT- IT IS
HOW
THE ACADEMY RECOGNIZES THE
DEDICATION AND COMMITMENT YOU
AND YOUR FAMILIES HAVE MADE FOR
YOUR EDUCATION, AND THE
EXPANSION OFUMAN KNOWLEDGE
WRIT LARGE. IT IS A MEANS BY
WHICH YOU CAN FULLY EMBODY THE
TRANSITION FROM GRADUATE
STUDENT
TO YOUR PROFESSIONAL
IDENTITIES.
IT IS ALSO A DAY FOR
CONGRATULATIONS. WE ACKNOWLEDGE
YOUR CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR
COMMUNITY AND TO YOUR
RESPECTIVE
DISCIPLINES. WE HOLD YOU IN A
COLLECTIVE EMBRACE BEFORE WE
SEND YOU OFF WITH OUR BEST
HOPES
AND WISHES.
YOU WILL CONTINUE TO LEARN, TO
DISCOVER, TO INVESTIGATE, TO
SHARE KNOWLEDGE; IT MAY  FAIR
SAY YR JONEY TO
KNOWLEDGE
HAS JUST BARELY BEGUN.
YET WE
RECOGNIZE AND MARK YOUR PASSAGE
FROM STUDENT TO TEACHER, FROM
LEARNER TO LEARNED.  IT IS A
PROFOUND REORIENTATION OF YOUR
PLACE IN THE WORLD AND DESERVES
TO BE ACKNOWLEDGED.
OVER YOUR TIME AT YALE YOU MAY
HAVE HEARD ME SAY THAT OUR
MISSION AS A SCHOOL IS TO TRAIN
SCHOLARS AND PUSH THE
BOUNDARIES
OF KNOWLEDGE -- THAT THIS
REQUIRES BEING COMFORTABLE WITH
UNCERTAINTY, AND THAT THE
SKILLS
YOU ACQUIRE WHILE DOING THIS
WILL MAKE YOU CAPABLE OF
TACKLING
DIFFICULT QUESTION WITH RIGOR
AND DISCIPLINE. WHILE IT'S
CERTAINLY TRUE THAT THE
PANDEMIC
PROFOUNDLY AFFECTED THE FINAL
STAGE OF YOUR TIME AT YALE, YOU
HAVE ADAPTED AND PERSEVERED TO
FINISH THE DEGREES YOU CAME TO
YALE TO ACCOMPLISH. YOU MAY
HAVE
HAD TO COPE WITH YOUR OWN
ILLNESS, THE ILLNESS OF FAMILY
MEMBERS, EVEN THE LOSS OF LOVED
ONES.  WE'VE ALL HAD TO LEARN
TO
DO EVERYTHING DIFFERENTLY, TO
COPE WITH TRAVEL DISRUPTIONS
AND
TO LIVE WITH UNCERTATY.
SPITE ESE STOR
DIFFICULTIES, YOU PERSISTED
WITH
COURAGE TO COMPLETE YOUR
STUDIES. YOU FOUND -- LIKE
OTHERS WHO HAVE GONE BEFORE --
THAT GRADUATE SCHOOL IS VERY
MUCH ABOUT NEGOTIATING THE
FRONTIER OF THE UNKNOWN.
EVEN NOW, THE PANDEMIC
HAS NOT ENTIRELY LOOSENED ITS
GRIP ON US; WE CANNOT YET
ASSESS
IT WITH THE CLARITY OF
HINDSIGHT.  BUT I HOPE AND
BELIEVE IT HAS PROVIDED US WITH
EXPERIENCE TO MAKE US BETTER
PROBLEM-SOLVERS, TO MAKE US
COMPASSIONE, MORTHOUTFUL
YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT YOU WILL BE
ASKED TO DO. BUT THE ABILITY TO
IDENTIFY A PROBLEM AND PURSUE
IT
TO SOLUTION IS A POWERFUL TOOL.
YOUR SKILL IN SOLVING COMPLEX
PROBLEMS, WORKING WITH OTHERS,
EMBRACING DIFFERENCES, AND
BUILDING CONSTRUCTIVE
RELATIONSHIPS WILL SERVE YOU
WELL WHEN FACED WITH THE
VICISSITUDES OF WORK AND LIFE.
CHALLENGES ARE CERTAIN; YOUR
ABILITIES ARE PROVEN. YOU ARE
READY FOR ALL OF IT.
PLEASE ALLOW ME TO TAKE A
MOMENT
HERE TO NAME SEVERAL GROUPS OF
YALE EMPLOYEES, BEYOND OUR
ESTABLISHED AND DEVOTED
FACULTY, WHO STAND AT THE HEART
OF YALE, AND WHEN I HAVE
FINISHED WE CAN THANK THEM
ALL TOGETHER.
THE UNIVERSITY'S CUSTODIAL AND
MAINTENANCE STAFF, WHO MAKE
YALE
LOOK BEAUTIFUL AND KEEP US IN
GOOD CONDITION ALL YEAR LONG.
THE HOSPITALITY STAFF, WHO FEED
US AT COMMENCEMENT AND
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR.
THE CLERICAL AND TECHNICAL
STAFF, WHO CONDUCT THE
UNIVERSITY'S BUSINESS WITH
ACUMEN AND DISPATCH.
THE MANAGERIAL AND PROFESSIONAL
STAFF, WHO DIRECT AND
ADMINISTER
OUR DEPARTMENTS AND SCHOOLS.
AND, SPECIFICALLY, THE STAFF OF
THE GRADUATE SCHOOL OF ARTS AND
SCIENCES WHO SUSTAIN THE
INSTITUTION WITHIN WHICH YALE
GRADUATE EDUCATION THRIVES.
NOW, FOR ALL OF THESE WONDERFUL
WOMEN AND MEN OF YALE, I ASK
FOR
YOUR RECOGNITION THROUGH
APPLAUSE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
AND NOW ON THIS DAY OF JOY AND
TOGETHERNESS, WE ARE PROUD TO
PRESENT YOU WITH A MENTO OF
YOUR TIME AT YALE.
PLEASE COME FORWARD WHEN DEAN
ALLEGRA DI BONAVENTURA READS
YOUR NAME. TO CONGRATULATE THE
DEGREE RECIPIENTS, WE WILL BE
JOINED AT THE FRONT OF THE
STAGE
BY FACULTY MEMBERS FROM
DEPARTMENTS AND PROGRAMS.
AND YES, YOU MAY APPLAUD AS YOU
SEE FIT.  IN FORMER TIMES, SUCH
APPLAUSE FOR INDIVIDUAL
GRADUATES MIGHT HAVE BEEN
THOUGHT A LITTLE BIT IMPOLITE.
BUT WE WELCOME IT, SO GO FOR
IT.
>> FOR THE DEGREES IN
AFRICAN-AMERICAN STUDIES.
FOR THE DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY.
SHANNA JEAN-BAPTISTE
[ APPLAUSE ]
BRITTANY LEVINGSTON
R THE DEGREES IN AMERICAN
STUDY THE DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY
COURTNEY SATO
[ APPLAUSE ]
DAMIAN VERGARA BRACAMONTES
ALEXIA WILLIAMS
[ APPLAUSE ]
FOR THE DEGREES IN ANTHROPOLOGY
THE DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY
HATICE ERTEN
[ APPLAUSE ]
ALYSSA PAREDES
JACOB RINCK
[ APPLAUSE ]
KYLE WILEY
FOR THE DEGREES IN APPLIED
PHYSICS
THE DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY
LINSHU LI
[ APPLAUSE ]
FOR THE MASTER OF SCIENCE
NASSER ALHOUTI
[ APPLAUSE ]
TIMO CHRISTEN
NIKITA ERMOLAEV
[ APPLAUSE ]
[ APPLAUSE
FOR THE DEGREES IN
ARCHAEOLOGICAL STUDIES
FOR THE MASTER OF ARTS DEGREE
ADRIAN NATALE
[ APPLAUSE ]
FOR THE DEGREES IN CELL BIOLOGY
THE DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY
JOSEPH AMICK
[ APPLAUSE ]
ANNA EASTMAN
KEVIN HUGHES
[ APPLAUSE ]
DAVID THALLER
WENPING ZHOU
[ APPLAUSE ]
FOR THE DEGREES IN CHEMISTRY
THE DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY
GOURAB BANERJEE
[ PLAUSE ]
IPSITA GHOSH
[ APPLAUSE ]
ANTHONY SCRUSE
FOR THE DEGREES IN
COMPUTATIONAL BIOLOGY AND
BIOINFORMATICS THE DOCTOR OF
PHILOSOPHY
DONGHOON LEE
[ APPLAUSE ]
KEVIN LOPEZ
FOR THE DEGREES IN COMPUTER
SCIENCE THE DOCTOR OF
PHILOSOPHY
LUCIANO DYBALLA
[ APPLAUSE ]
JÉRÉMIE KOENIG
MARKO MITROVIC
[ APPLAUSE ]
RUI ZHANG
FOR THE MASTER OF SCIENCE
DEGREE
DIMING CHU
[ APPLAUSE ]
WEI JIANG
YINGHAO WANG
[ APPLAUSE ]
FOR DEGREES IN EARTH AND
PLANETARY SCIENCES THE DOCTOR
OF PHILOSOPHY
NEALA CREASY
[ APPLAUSE ]
CHHAVI JAIN
YOSHINORI MIYAZAKI
[ APPLAUSE ]
SARAH ARVESON
FOR THE DEGREES IN ECOLOGY AND
EVOLUTIONARY BIOLOGY
THE DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY
LARRY.
[ APPLAUSE ]
JESSICA GLASS
FOR THE DEGREES IN ECONOMICS
THE DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY
IAN BALL
[ APPLAUSE ]
EDUARDO PINHEIRO FRAGA
OREN SARIG
[ APPLAUSE ]
SOUMITRA SHUKLA
NICHOLAS SNASHALL-WOODHAMS
[ APPLAUSE ]
CONOR WALSH
YUZHOU WANG
[ APPLAUSE ]
FOR THE DEGREES IN ENGINEERING
AND APPLIED SCIENCE
THE PROGRAM IN BIOMEDICAL
ENGINEERING
THE DEGREE OF DOCTOR OF
PHILOSOPHY
[ APPLAUSE ]
AYOMIPOSI LOYE
MICHA SAM RAREDON
[ APPLAUSE ]
FOR THE MASTER OF SCIENCE
DEGREE
SHUOZHEN BAO
[ APPLAUSE ]
FAR THE PROGRAM IN CHEMICAL AND
ENVIRONMENTAL ENGINEERING
THE DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY
RANDOLPH CALLENDER
[ APPLAUSE ]
AKSHAY DESHMUKH
FOR THE MASTER OF SCIENCE
DEGREE
SHURAN WEI
[ APPLAUSE ]
THE PROGRAM IN ELECTRICAL
ENGINEERING
THE DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY
MEHRAVEH SALEHI
[ APPLAUSE ]
FOR THE PROGRAM IN MECHANICAL
ENGINEERING MATERIAL SCIENCE
THE DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY
GENTLEMAN
SUBHAJYOTI CHAUDHURI
RODRIGO MIGUEL OJEDA MOTA
[ APPLAUSE ]
QIKAI WU
YINGJIE XIANG
[ APPLAUSE ]
CHAO ZHOU
YUJUN XIE
[ APPLAUSE ]
FOR DEGREES IN ENVIRONMENT
THE DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY
KANGNING HUANG
[ APPLAUSE ]
LAUREN PINCUS
FOR THE DEGREES IN EUROPEAN AND
THE MASTER OF ARTS
MADELEINE MUZDAKIS
[ APPLAUSE ]
FOR THE DEGREES IN EXPERIMENTAL
PATHOLOGY, THE DOCTOR OF
PHILOSOPHY
YUTING LIU
[ APPLAUSE ]
FOR THE DEGREES IN GENETICS
THE DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY
DANIEL BURKHARDT
[ APPLAUSE ]
JULIANNE GERDES
DIANE MANRY
[ APPLAUSE ]
MICHAEL SIERANT
JAE EUN SONG
[ APPLAUSE ]
XUE ZENG
FOR THE DEGREES IN HISTORY
THE DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY
KEVIN FEENEY
[ APPLAUSE ]
MIREILLE PARDON
JUSTIN RANDOLPH
[ APPLAUSE ]
FOR THE MASTER OF ARTS
KEITH (KC) O'HARA
[ APPLAUSE ]
HARRY PERKIN
FOR DEGREES IN HISTORY OF ART
THE DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY
LAURA PHILLIPS
[ APPLAUSE ]
FOR DEGREES IN HISTORY OF
SCIENCE AND MEDICINE
THE DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY
HAESOO PARK
[ APPLAUSE ]
ASHANTI SHIH
FOR THE DEGREES IN IMMUNO
BIOLOGY, THE DOCTOR OF
PHILOSOPHY
PING-MIN CHEN
[ APPLAUSE ]
FOR DEGREES IN THE
INTERDEPARTMENTAL NEUROSCIENCE
PROGRAM
THE DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY
USMAN FAROOQ
[ APPLAUSE ]
TIANLIUYUN GAO
JIE LISA JI
[ APPLAUSE ]
LIEN NGUYEN
FOR THE DEGREES IN
INTERNATIONAL AND DEVELOPMENT
ECONOMICS
THE MASTER OF ARTS
JASMIN BAIER
[ APPLAUSE ]
SANJAM CHHABRA
SHWETHA EAPEN
[ APPLAUSE ]
YIJIA GAO
VALENTINA GOETZ
[ APPLAUSE ]
PABLO ANTONIO GORDILLO COUTIÑO
RHEA GUPTA
[ APPLAUSE ]
PREKSHA JAIN
MARK KHALIL
[ APAUSE ]
DALTON MATTSON
[ APPLAUSE ]
SHREEMAYI SAMUJJWALA
NISHKA SHARMA
[ APPLAUSE ]
PO-AN SHIH
ASTHA VOHRA
[ APPLAUSE ]
RONGXUAN ZHANG
[ APPLAU ]
[ APPLAUSE ]
FOR THE DEGREES IN ITALIAN
STUDY
THE DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY
JULIA PUCCI
[ APPLAUSE ]
FOR THE DEGREES IN LINGUISTICS
THE DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY
RIKKER DOCKUM
[ APPLAUSE ]
MARTIN FUCHS
FOR THE DEGREES IN MANAGEMENT
THE DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY
MARGEUM KIM
[ APPLAUSE ]
FOR THE DEGREES IN MATHEMATICS
THE DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY
GUANGYU ZHU
[ APPLAUSE ]
FOR THE DEGREES IN MEDIEVAL
STUDIES
THE DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY
SEBASTIAN BEZERRA
[ APPLAUSE ]
GINA HURLEY
FOR THE DEGREES IN MICROBIOLOGY
THE DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY
KELSEY HAUGH
[ APPLAUSE ]
EMILY PUTNAM
EMILEE SHINE
[ APPLAUSE ]
FOR THE DEGREES IN MOLECULAR
BIOPHYSICS AND BIO CHEMISTRY,
THE DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY
KENNETH BREWER
[ APPLAUSE ]
KIRSTEN KNECHT
FOR THE DEGREES IN MOLECULAR,
CELLULAR, AND DEVELOPMENTAL
BIOLOGY
THE DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY
KOEN VANDERSCHUREN
[ APPLAUSE ]
FOR THE DROOS
FOR THE DEGREES IN MUSIC
THE CTOR OF PHILOSHY
STEFANIE ACEVEDO
[ APPLAUSE ]
LAURA BROWN
BRIANNE DOLCE
[ APPLAUSE ]
LIAM HYNES-TAWA
BRIAN LLER
[ APPLAUSE ]
WILLIAM WATSON
FOR THE MASTER OF ARTS
HARRY CASTLE
[ APPLAUSE ]
FOR THE DEGREES IN NURSING
THE DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY
BRIDGET BASILE IBRAHIM
[ APPLAUSE ]
ABBE MULLER
FOR THE DEGREES IN PHARMACOLOGY
THE DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY
ERIC ROSENBERG
[ APPLAUSE ]
FOR THE DEGREES IN PHILOSOPHY
THE DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY
REIER HELLE
[ APPLAUSE ]
FOR THE DEGREES IN PHYSICS
THE DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY
SUPRAJA BALASUBRAMANIAN
[ APPLAUSE ]
CHARLES BROWN II
CHRISTOPHER DAVIS
[ APPLAUSE ]
ARPIT DUA
RAYMOND EHLERS III
[ APPLAUSE ]
TYLER LUTZ
KYUNGJOO NOH
[ APPLAUSE ]
CHRISTIAN WEBER
FOR THE DEGREES IN POLITICAL
SCIENCE
THE DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY
MAXIMILIAN KRAHÉ
[ APPLAUSE ]
GAUTAM NAIR
MATTHEW SHAFER
[ APPLAUSE ]
ALICIA STEINMETZ
FOR DEGREES IN PSYCHOLOGY
THE DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY
ELIZABETH LEWIS
[ APPLAUSE ]
FOR THE DEGREES IF PUBLIC
HEALTH
THE DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY
E-SHIEN CHANG
[ APPLAUSE ]
MO LI
RENEE MEHR
[ APPLAUSE ]
XIAOCHEN WANG
THE MASTER OF SCNCE
WENHAN LU
[ APPLAUSE ]
GENTLEMAN
ZIYI TANG
WEI TIAN
[ APPLAUSE ]
YUMIN WANG
YUXUAN WANG
[ APPLAUSE ]
NING ZHANG
GENTLEMAN FOR
FOR THE DEGREES IN RELIGIOUS
STUDIES
THE DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY
JOSEPHUMMI
[ APPLAUSE ]
PRATIMA GOPALAKRISHNAN
LUCIA HULSETHER
[ APPLAUSE ]
JUSTIN WHITE
FOR DEGREES IN SLAVIC LANAGES
AND LITERATURES
THE DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY
JACOB LASSIN
[ APPLAUSE ]
FOR THE DEGREES IN SOCIOLOGY
THE DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY
MUSTAFA YAVAS
[ APPLAUSE ]
FOR THE DEGREES IN STATISTICS
AND DATA SCIENCE THE DOCTOR OF
PHILOSOPHY
ELENA KHUSAINOVA
[ APPLAUSE ]
TAL SARIG
XIN XU
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> OKAY, GRADUATES.
HANG ON.
VY TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE IT --
OKAY.
I'M GOING TO NOW ASK, AS I CALL
OUT EACH DEGREE, TO HAVE THE
RECIPIENTS OF THOSE DEGREES
STAND AND REMAIN STANDING AFTER
WHICH WE CAN ALL CONGRATULATE
YOU COLLECTIVELY ON YOUR
MARVELOUS ACHIEVEMENTS.
MASTER OF ARTS.
MASTER OF SCIENCE
DOCTOR OF PHILOSOPHY
[ APPLAUSE ]
OKAY.
PLEASE STAY STANDING FOR JUST A
MOMENT.
IT'S OUR TRADITION IN THE
GRADUATE SCHOOL TO RECOGNIZE
THAT THE COMMITMENT OF TIME,
EFFORT AND ATTENTION REQUIRED
TO
ACHIEVE YOUR ADVANCED DEGREE
WAS ONLY POSSIBLE WITH THE
PARTICIPATION AND SUPPORT OF
NOT
ONLY OUR PROFESSORS AND
CLASSMATES, BUT ALSO OUR
FAMILIES AND FRIENDS.
I INVITE YOU TO TURN TO THOSE
IN THE ROOM WITH YOU TODAY AND
ACKNOWLEDGE THE HELP THEY'VE
GIVEN TO YOU REACH YOUR
DEGREES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
OKAY.
YOU CAN SIT DOWN NOW.
YOU HAVE BEEN AN INTEGRAL PART
OF ONE OF CIVILIZATION'S
HIGHEST
INVENTIONS - THE RESEARCH
UNIVERSITY WHERE THE MISSION IS
THE CREATION OF NEW KNOWLEDGE.
AS YOU HAVE LEARNED, FINDING
NEW
KNOWLEDGE, NEW TRUTH, ABOUT OUR
WORLD IS NOT A SOLITARY
ENDEAVOR. YOU HAVE LIVED WITHIN
AN ACADEMIC NETWORK IN WHICH
YOU
CAN FOLLOW YOUR CURIOSITY,
RIGOROUSLY TEST YOUR IDEAS,
BENEFIT FROM CRITIQUE, AND GO
FORWARD IN AN UNEXPECTED
DIRECTION. YOU HAVE LEARNED
THAT
A CONVINCING ARGUMENT BACKED BY
EVIDENCE FROM PRIMARY SOURCES
OR
WELL-CONTROLLED EXPERIMENTS
WILL
STAND UP TO CRITIQUES AND,
IMPORTANTLY, PAVE THE WAY FOR
THE NEXT PERSON TO TAKE ANOTHER
STEP. SAVOR THIS. REJOICE IN
THIS. IT IS A RARE PRIVILEGE TO
HAVE HAD EXPERIENCE AND TO
APPLY
WHAT YOU HAVE LEARNED
THROUGHOUT
YOUR LIFE.
FINALLY, PLEASE TAKE A MOMENT
TO
REFLECT ON THE PEOPLE WHO
HELPED
YOU TO MAKE IT THROUGH GRADUATE
SCHOOL, TO FIND YOUR CAREER
PATH. AS YOU BENEFITTED FROM
BEING MENTORED, CONSIDER BEING
A
MENTOR YOURSELF. THINK ABOUT
SHARING YOUR KNOWLEDGE AND
EXPERIENCE WITH UPCOMING
STUDENTS THROUGH THE GRADUATE
SCHOOL ALUMNI ASSOCIATION, OR
BY SIGNING UP TO BE PART OF
CROSS-CAMPUS, OUR PORTAL FOR
BRINGING ALUMNI AND CURRENT
GRADUATE STUDENTS TOGETHER FOR
NETWORKING AND CAREER SUPPORT.
YOU MAY NOT REALIZE HOW MUCH
YOUR EXPERIENCES CAN ALREADY BE
OF BENEFIT TO OTHERS.
GRADUATES, FRIENDS,
FAMILIES, TOGETHER WITH THE
FACULTY AND STAFF WHO ARE WITH
US, YOU ARE ALL INVITED TO A
RECEPTION
IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING THE
CEREMONY IN
THE CAULKINS COURTYARD AT THE
McDOUGAL CENTER.
WHERE WE STARTED OUT THIS
MORNING.
PLEASE JOIN US
FOR THIS CELEBRATORY OCCASION.
PLEASE REMAIN IN YOUR SEATS
UNTIL THE PLATFORM PARTY
RECESSES FROM THE AUDITORIUM.
THEN PROCESS YOURSELVES OUT TO
THE RECEPTION UNDER THE
GUIDANCE OF OUR USHERS.
ON BEHALF OF ALL OF US AT YALE,
CONGRATULATIONS!
[ APPLAUSE ]
♪